[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم يتواصل الجدل في مصر بدقه
الارقام المتداوله حول اعداد ما شاركوا في
حدود الثلاثين من الماضي ضد الرئيس
المعزول محمد مرسي فقد شكك البعض في
امكانيه استيعاب ميدان التحرير والشوارع
وساحات تجمع تلك الحشود بشعابها الاعداد
المتداوله في هذا الصدد نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقشه في محورين ما هي الاسس التي
استند اليها معارضو مرسي في تقدير عدد
المشاركين في حشود ثلاثين مليون يورو
وما مدى منطقيه الربط بين صحه الارقام
المتداوله لاعداد المشاركين في ذلك الحشد
ومن بني عليها للقرارات
ب
مثل ما يجادل مؤيد وعزل الرئيس محمد مرسي
بان خطوه عزيز من قبل الجيش جاءت استنادا
الى ما اطلقوا عليه شرعيه الشارع اثار
التفاوت المتسارع في تقدير اعداد من خرجوا
في مسيره الثلاثين من يونيو المعارضه
المعارضه لمرسي اكثر من تساؤل وبينما يغيب
مصدر هذه الارقام المعلنه والتي اوصلها
البعض الى عتبه الثلاثين من ثلاثين مليون
متظاهر او اكثر يذهب مختصون و مؤسسات
اعلاميه للتشكيك في هذه الارقام وفي
مشروعيه توظيفها في مرحله مفصليه من
التاريخ السياسي المصري والعربي اضاءه على
الحدث وارقامه مع الزميل عبد القادر عرضه
الثلاثين من يونيو حزيران الماضي باعداد
غفيره والى شوارع القاهره ومحافظات اخرى
مثلا متظاهرون المعارضين للرئيس محمد مرسي
اول رئيس منتخب ديمقراطيا
تدخل الجيش وعزل مرسي مستندا في قراره على
نداء هذه الحشود كما قال والتي تفاوت
تقدير اعدادها
استخدمت المروحيات العسكريه لتصوير
المظاهرات وتسويقها للاعلام والعالم واضحت
ارقام المتظاهرين
سباق الارقام هذا اثار تساؤلات حسابيه قبل
ان تكون سياسيه استشهد البعض
وعلى غير العاده اصدرت شركه جوجل تصريحات
نصر من هذه الادعاءات جميع الاحصاءات التي
نسبت الينا سواء فيما يتعلق بالتظاهرات
الثلاثين من يونيو الماضي او التظاهرات
المؤيده للرئيس المعزول محمد مرسي هي
احصاءات وهميه
وبعيدا عن الخوض في اعداد المتظاهرين حول
محللون ومختصون ومواقع اعلاميه غربيه
توظيف تقنيه روبيرت ليس في حصر الاعداد
ولكن في قياس مساحات وبالتالي قدره
الشوارع والميادين على استيعاب المتظاهرين
وجد هؤلاء ان مساحه ميدان التحرير لا
تتجاوز باي حال من الاحوال ثلاثه وخمسين
الف متر مربع و بتوسيع المساحه لتشمل
الميدان وكل الشوارع المحيطه به وصولا الى
جسر السادس من اكتوبر و جسر قصر النيل
فانها لن تتجاوز مائه وثلاثين الف متر
مربع وتتسع لحوالي خمس مائه وسته عشر الف
شخص بمعدل اربعه اشخاص في المتر المربع
وفقا للمعايير العالميه ميدان اخر شهد
الحشود وهو محيط القصر الرئاسي في
الاتحاديه اذ احتشد امامه الالاف على طول
بلغ حوالي الف واربعمائه متر وبعرض بلغ
خمسه واربعين مترا من يعني مساحه اجماليه
قدرها ثلاثه وستون الف متر مربع كما كانت
هناك مظاهره اخرى شمال القصر على مساحه
تبلغ حوالي تسعه الاف متر مربع من يعني
ارتفاع المساحه المتاحه في محيط قصر
الاتحاديه باكمله الى اثنين وسبعين الف
متر مربع تتسع لحوالي ثلاثمائه الف شخص في
اعلى تقدير
وبالتالي فان مجموعه متظاهر الثلاثين من
يونيو في اكبر تجمعين جرى الاستشهاد بهما
يتجاوز بقليل ثمانمائه الف متظاهر اي اقل
من مليون على مساحه اجماليه قدرها نحو
مائتي الف متر مربع
اذن مائه الف متر مربع وهي ماتعادل الستين
في المائه من مساحه الحرم المكي احد اكبر
ميادين الاحتشاد في العالم خصوصا في ذروه
موسم الحج مساحه المسجد الحرام بما فيها
مساحه مختلف الطوابق بحسب تقديرات رسميه
سعوديه
تقدر الان ب حوالي ثلاث مائه وستين الف
متر مربع تستوعب في اقصى تقدير للسلطات
السعوديه نفسها مليون وربع المليون في
اوقات الاحتشاد التام اذن مساحه الحرم
تستوعب مليونا وربع المليون المصلى
بينما مساحه ميدان التحرير ومحيط
الاتحاديه التي تجاوزت مائتي الف متر مربع
ف تستوعب اكثر من ثمانمائه الف شخص اي اقل
من مليون متظاهر
يقول الباحثون عن حقيقه ماجرى صحيح ان
محافظه اخرى شهدت ايضا مظاهرات الا انهم
يجزمون بان المظاهرات الرئيسيه الكبرى جرت
في التحرير والاتحاديه في القاهره التي
يسكنها اصلا نحو خمس سكان مصر
بعمليه حسابيه اخرى خمس سكان مصر وهو عدد
سكان القاهره تقريبا خرج منه ما يقل عن
المليون ولو ان كثافه الاحتشاد كان
اهدافها في كافه المحافظات الاخرى وتوصلنا
الى نتيجه تقول ان حوالي اربعه ملايين شخص
في اقصى تقدير خرجوا في تظاهرات الثلاثين
من يونيو
موضوع حلقتنا هذه نناقشه مع ضيوفنا في
الاستوديو
والقليل مدير تحرير صحيفه الشروق المصريه
عمر هاشم ربيع اه رئيس برنامج التحول
الديمقراطي خبير الشئون البرلمانيه
والحزبيه بمركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه
اه سيد عمر هاشم يمكنك ان تضع الان
ميكروفون امامك حان الوقت قال ذلك اسال اه
اه القضيه لك ان تعلق على هذه الارقام
مديره الدراسات التي قدرت مساحه بحوالي
الف متر مربع لميدان التحرير وباقي
الشوارع الاخرى وقالت بانها لا يمكن ان
تستوعب كل هذه الملايين التي تحدث عنها اه
هذا حقيقي
ومحاوله تثبيت اه اكذوبه او وهم الثلاثين
مليون او الاربعين مليون اه ربما بدات منذ
الثلاثين من يونيو وكان يلفت النظر في هذه
المساله ان الاصرار على رقم ثلاثين اه
ثلاثين مليون وكان يتردد بشكل شبه اه
منتظم وكانه نصا وكان له نص موزع اه على
كل ال السنه سواء في
او في ال الداء لثلاثين او حتى في الخطاب
الرسمي والمؤسسه العسكريه ونعلم جيدا ان
صناعه هذه الصوره كانت ال الت التي استند
اليها قرار الانقلاب او قرار وزير الدفاع
بعزل الرئيس محمد مرسي وال اطاح بالرئيس
محمد مرسي في ذلك الوقت هذا الكلام ليس
جديد او سبقته دراسات علميه ل اه اه هيئه
الاذاعه البريطانيه استنادا الى استاذ
الرياضيات في كانت لندن
هنا وفي راي اكدت في انها ال اه هذا
القياس قياس الارقام بهذه الطريقه لا يؤدي
ابدا الى الارقام ال ال الاسطوريه التي
ذكرت ثلاثين مليون وما الى ذلك وضربت مثلا
ب اه حفل تنصيب باراك اوباما وقالت انه
بال بال مقاييس العلميه لم يكن العدد
تجاوز مدينه مائه الف نفس الشيء اكده اه
مراسل الشرق الاوسط في ال في البي بي سي
وقال ان الاعداد باي حال من الاحوال وفقا
لقياسات علميه دقيقه لا تزيد عن سبعمائه
الف هناك اه احد المهندسين المصريين خبير
في هذا الشان امجد المنزل
ونقلا عن استاذ فهمي نشرت دراسه وفيلم
استمرار عشر دقائق حسب فيه فعلا المساحات
ميدان التحرير و وال كثافه في ساعه الذروه
وساعه المتر المربع للاشخاص وتوصل الى ان
الرقم في ميدان التحرير والاتحاديه
استاذ عمر هاشم السؤال كيف اللي وجهها لك
في بدايه للتعليق على هذه الارقام لانها
عكس ما تقول هو عكس ما يتداول الان في
معسكر المؤيد لما حدث في ثلاثين وفي
الثالث من يونيو لا انا تاجيل السودان هذا
الكلام
الارض في التقرير هو محاوله لتسويه الموقف
محاوله اللحظه عليه هو محاوله ل ل اه اه
تسويه هذا الحشد الكبير الذي حدث حدث
بالفعل الحشد الكبير اه مش واضح بالتاكيد
الا وكل الكلام اللي هو الصدر كان متعلق
بميدان التحرير
ابدا سكوير
وال والشوارع المحيطه به احنا عندنا صور
وشفنا الشوارع المحيطه الاتحاديه ذلك اه
اه تم اه يعني تحديد الارقام التي يمكن ان
تكون خرجت يعني على المحاضرات اللي كان
معروض كان الكلام على
المدن التحرير طبعا في
كبير اه
حجم الحجم الميدان وعشرين الف متر لكن
لكن هذا نحنا قلنا ثلاثه وخمسين الف
الكلام عن مناطق محيطه المنطقه المحيطه
منه وخارج من شوارع ويصير خارج من شارع
عمر مكرم ثلاثمائه متر الشارع الكوبي
الحقيقه الكبرى بطول ست وتسع مائه متر
خارج من الشارع اللي بيطلع على مس بيروت
مائه متر رمسيس والمرور المنعم رياض واشار
عمليات واحد كيلو متر الف متر يعني اه
ستمائه متر عاصي النيل تكون مائه متر شارع
طلعت حرب
شارع محمد محمود والموقف كيلو تقريبا
الشرع اسلاميه هذا الحاجه للتحليل كما
قلنا في التقرير حياه الحال كل هذه
الشوارع ذكرناها في التقرير مع ميدان
التحرير يصل ساعتها مائه وثلاثين الف متر
مربع هذا الشوارع
كل الشوارع هذه هي محاوله بالتاكيد لتحكيم
العدد الرغم على الرغم ان جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين ذاتها هي التي الف القوات كلها
يعني
عندما لحق بالثوره وقفت على عليها يوم
تسعه وعشرين يناير كان بتقول المدن في
ثلاثه مليون وربع
هذا من جماعه الاخوان المسلمين عندما
عندما ركبت القطار
الثوره في بعدما اندلعت فرض سيطره ايام من
تسعه وعشرين وثلاثين يناير الفين وواحد
وصل
ان الميدان به كذا وكذا وكذا
الاخوان المسلمين التي
يعني انا ما عم بيشكل لك ان تكمل
[ضحك]
اذا اضافت الى ذلك الاتحاديه
كبير عرضه اكثر من ثمانين مائه العرض اكثر
واكثر من كيلو واذا
محيط قصر القبه هذا التجاهل التقرير تماما
لان ذكر خارج من المظاهرات
الميادين ميادين مصر كلها
في الاسكندريه تحديدا واكثر من ميدان لا
يتبين طبعا ان نقول لهذه الكلام الغرض منه
تسويه الجموع التي خرجت اه
في
التقرير
تقول انها تقرير لم يرد فيه
محيط قصر الرئاسي في الاتحاديه شهدها
الاف امامه على طول شارع بلغ حوالي الف
واربعمائه متر وبعرض بلغ خمسه واربعين متر
مربع وهذا ان كانت انه ورد في التقرير على
كل حال الخطوره اين الخطوره ان هذه
الارقام المتداوله والتي قالت بالملايين
انا لا اعتقد الانسان الذي يلحق انا اعترض
وانما هناك فقط اسال ا نبني عليها قرارات
خطيره هم مصير بلد باكمله قرارات ادت الى
عزل الرئيس اه اه ال ال ال ال اه المخلوع
محمد مرسي الذي جاء ب صناديق يا ترى ادت
الى توقيف مساله الديمقراطي كان يعاملها
عليه المصريون لبناء مصر ديمقراطيه مصر
المؤسسات وبالتالي الان اصبحت البلاد في
مهب الريح اذا شئنا ان نقول البلاد
المعارضه ل هزات خطيره جدا اه
الارقام
يعني
اه هنا في حتى اثنين اولا في انتخابات
الرئاسه المرحله الثانيه في الاستفتاء
والعمليه الرئيس مرسي تحديدا عندما حصل
على
واحد وخمسين الف ثلاثه وسبعين في المائه
من على الاسواق
مليون وخمسمائه ثلاثه وعشرين الف مائه
وثلاثين صوت مقابل طبعا الطرف الاخر عكس
المائه في المائه يعني اثناشر مليون صوت
وسبعه الفين هذه الارقام بس يعني ال ال ال
اكثر من نصف اه
طبعا هما ذكروا جماعه الاخوان
باكثر من نصف هذه الارقام
القوى المدنيه والقوه التي القوه القوى
الثوريه التي كانت تعارض فلول النظام
السابق
استاذ علوم سياسيه عندما نتحدث عن ميادين
ب نتحدث عن مساحه وليس لا يوجد شيء اسمه
حجم الميدان
ثانيا نحن امام صناع الصوره في فيلم
سينمائي
تم تصدير هذه الارقام مسبقا كما تم تصدير
بيان الانقلاب قبل ان تخرج جماهير الى
الشارع واحيلك هنا الى كلام السيد ابو ما
بين على انها في التاسعه صباحا كان القرار
او البيان
جاهز لاستدعاء الجيش لكي يحدث انقلابا ثم
جاءت ال الحشود وتصوير الحشود لكي يكمل
هذه الصوره ما يقال عن ان شعبيه الرئيس
محمد مرسي انخفضت ا واظهرت نتائج
الاستفتاء على الدستور انخفاض شعبيه الاسم
احمد العكس هو الصحيح يا سيدي لان الاجراء
الذي يمكن ان تقراه في هذه الارقام انه
ربما انخفضت شعبيه جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
في الشارع ولكننا سهم الرئيس محمد مرسي
ارتفعت في الاستفتاء على التعديلات
الدستوريه
عندما اقول ان محمد مرسي حصل على واحد
وخمسين في المائه في جوله الاعاده
يتم التحقق دائما ان محمد مرشح الجوله
الاولى من الانتخابات الرئاسيه لم يحصل
الا على سته ملايين هذا جيدا عندما تكون
بين سبعه متنافسين
وتحصل على سته ملايين ست وتحصل المركز
الاول فهذا يعني وبالتالي في جوله الاعاده
مع اصطفاف بين اه القوه المدنيه الشريكه
في وثلاثين يونيو الان الى جبهه احمد شفيق
وهذا ثابت
حتى نعود الى
هذا ليس موضوعا
ل لاعود الى
انتم التحدث عن
يعني هذه الارقام وهذه الملايين من اين
جاءت الارقام على امانه المسيرات في حين
اطلق هذا الرقم من اطلق هذا الرقم وعلى
على اي اساس
الارقام طبعا طبعا
ما بين اربعطاش لغايه ثلاثين يعني هذا
فارق كبير وصلت اربعين في
ان كل الطرف يسعى دائما الى تعظيم الحاجه
دقيقه لكن بقول لحضرتك
بهذا ال كوبر وحاولت ما محاور مقابل ميدان
من مقابل يعني شارع متقاطع و وشارع النصر
مع شركه طيران تقول عليهم هو
المقاومه
فقط فقط عن اليوم ثلاثين يوم ان تلك
الحشود التى خرجت ولكن بنا على ارقام ها
كل تلك القرارات
اللي الحاجه نفس الكلام اللي
عليه على شارع التقاطع النصر مع ربع
العدويه على ايه علينا حجم الميدان سته
خمسه وثلاثين متر الميدان
اربعه اشخاص بيتكلم على سته وعشرين
سبعه وعشرين الف انا اتحدث يعني وثلاثين
الارقام التي يعني اصر عليها معسكر يعني
المؤيده
في المائه
هذا الرقم وعلى اي اساس
نهائيا
الوزير
على الاتحاد الاوروبي اللي كان
على الاتحاد الاوروبي
فقط اسمح لي يا اما نتحدث بما
على محور النقاش وهو يوم ثلاثين وهذه
الثلاثين مليون التي يعني نضجت بها الدنيا
والكل يردد وهو اعتماد على قاعده كله ما
تقرر حتى يعني وكاننا اصبحت بالنسبه اليها
مسلمه في اماكن
بورسعيد ولكن الزخم الذي يمكن ان يخرج من
التحرير والشوارع المحيطه به والقاهره قيل
بان الاعداد التي يمكن ان تستوعبها كل هذه
الشوارع لا يمكن ان تتجاوز اربعه مليون
ونحن نعلم ان حوالي خمس سكان المصرفي
القاهره والمحافظات المحيطه بها وبالتالي
يعني في فئه في القاهره اربعه مليون اذا
اذا اذا ثمانمائه الف عفوا الف اذا
اعتبرنا ان القاهره خمس سكان البلاد مائه
الف وخمسه يعني اربعه
انا
يعني بلش الميادين وبلشوا انتخابات
الرئاسه وانتخابات الدستور اللي اللي
الشعب المصري الك على الوقت والاستاذ
حاجه ثانيه استمارات تمرد اللي تجاوزت سته
وعشرين مليون
عبد الماجد
اتحدث عن الحشود التي
انا انا وانت
التوقيعات
اتفضل احنا نشوف استاذنا
الانقلاب ثلاثين يوليو صناعه السينمائيه
بانتهاك بالضبط كما هي استمارات تموز عداد
استمارات تمرد عندما خرجت التجرد تقول
اننا ارسلنا 15 مليون فجاه
رفعت المؤشر تمرد الى عشرين مليون وثلاثين
مليون هذا الموضوع كله
فكره ان ثلاثين مليون اه اه اه مصر يوقعون
على استمارات هذه مستحيله لانهم لم يخرجوا
اصلا في انتخابات او في اضيف الى ارقام ال
ال التقرير التي تحدثت عن 800 1000 م
قياسا بما يقال عن ان ثلاثين واربعين الف
وخارج ان عدد عشرين في المائه من سكان مصر
خمسه اطفال تحت سن العاشره
خمس سكان مصر عشرين في المائه من تعداد
سكان المصريين تحت سن العاشره وهذا في في
اه اه الارقام ال الجهاز المركزي للتعبئه
العامه والاحصاء ويستطيع ان الرجوع اليها
وبالتالي عندما تتحدث عن ثلاثين واربعين
وانت تتحدث عن نصف الشعب المصري
الواضح ان هناك يعني اه اه
القرارات الخطيره التي بنيت عليها هذه
الارقام الا تسلم المصداقيه والشرعيه من
كل ما ما ما ترتب عليها بالتاكيد وحتى لو
ان هذه الارقام صحيحه هزيله تعطي الشرعيه
انت ك هكذا تمارس ديمقراطيه الشارع تمارس
ديمقراطيه الرؤوس او ال او ال او العام او
ال او ال ال الشعبويه وليس الشعبيه لانها
التعبير عن الديمقراطيه بالمفهوم العلمي
بالوسائل العلميه هو ان تذهب الى صناديق
شفافه لكي قبل واربع هذه الديمقراطيه
وبالتالي سواء كانت الارقام واهميه وهي
واهميه و اسطوريه او كانت قريبه من الواقع
هي لا تصلح حجه لكي عمليه ديمقراطيه من
الاساس لكي تلغي بقرار من من شخصيه واحده
دستورا وتسقط رئيسا منتخبا وتعيد اه اه
الاجواء مصر السياسي الى ما قبل الثوره
التي قامت في خمسه وعشرين نائب نحن الان
يعني نعيش اجواء ثوره مضاده بكل المعنى
الكامل للثوره الموضوع اسمح لي يعني هذه
نقطه في غايه الاهميه يعني بدل ان اسيره
في هذا الجدل كمخرج وكما لم يخرج الا
يفترض ان يتم الاحتكام الى شيء اساسي
وواقعي وهو الذي يمكن ان يكون له الفصل
وهو صندوق الاقتراع نعم بالتاكيد هذا هذا
اللجوء الى
عندما سحب الشعب التوكيل الذي اعطاه
بالرئيس هون كانت
التوكيل عندما سحب التوكيل اقرب انتخابات
برلمانيه ورئاسيه
هذا الكلام
هذا كل ما قال ان هذه الاليه المشروعه
عندنا امكانيه سحب الثقه من الرئيس اكثر
خارجي
المشكله
مشكله اساسيه ان الشعب المصري
رفض كامل وهذا يمكن يتضح ان شاء الله في
الانتخابات البرلمانيه والرئاسيه القادمه
سياسي هذا امر مرفوض انك توصف الشعب تقسيم
والكفره وال وال وال متدينين هذا الامر في
نوع من ال من الحاله
لم يقولوا اه اه في يوم سته وعشرين وسيخرج
المصريون الشرفاء
بتفويض الرئيس اه راى وزير الدفاع السياسي
العسكريه كان
ما فيه مشكله لانه الشرفاء وبمفهوم
المخالفه الاخرين غير الشرفاء يا سيدي
تفضل الى تعليق الاخير يعني دستوريا
وديمقراطيه هناك ثلاث حالات لسحب الثقه من
رئيس واسقاط الرئيس يحددها الدستور
ويحددها البرلمان مثلا اذا كان ثبت انه
غير مؤهل بدنيا ولا عقليا او او ثانيا اذا
دعا الرئيس الشعب للاستفتاء على البرلمان
ولم اه
ولم يقرر الشعب حل البرلمان في هذه الحاله
لا بد ان يتنحى الرئيس لانه هناك وسائل
كثيره جدا لتغيير الرئيس كان يكفلها
الدستور الذي س تحت اقدام العسكر وفرض مره
اخرى ان هناك فارقا كبيرا بين حشود تاتي
في رعايه الجيش والشرطه وتقدم لها الهدايا
وتقدر يعني كان خارجه الى كرنفال احتفالي
وبين حشود نرى ما نراه الان من تحرش بها
وترصد بها وتهديدات بحرب اباده تشبه ما
دار في البوسنه والهرسك ومن حشود تهدد
يوميا وتخون يوميه
وتنقلها الروايات الامنيه عن ال الامراض
داخل رابعه العدويه وما الى ذلك ام في
طريق الاخير هذه الارقام ومصداقيه منبني
عليها في عشرين ثانيه من فضلك اه انا
اتصور ان ال ما ذكرته فيما يتعلق بموضوع
الشرفاء وموضوع فيما يتعلق بالثقافه اللي
ب ترمى هنا ورد الاعلام وتامين بيان
الامور كلها
اسالك في وقت في
بدايه الحلقه نعم السؤال
تاثير هذه الارقام على مشروعيه منبني
عليها مشروعه بالتاكيد مشروع بالتاكيد
لانك انت بتتكلم على حشود كبيره بيتكلم
على انتكاسات في المجال الصحي والاجتماعي
عليها كل المؤشرات الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
في حدود انتكاسات لم يثبت مشادات ماشافش
هذه الانتكاسات الكبيره التي مما يجعل
هناك ضروره في ان يكون هناك انتخابات
قادمه اه وهذه الان انا اتصور ان الشعب
يكون جديد بان فكما هو تلازم بين الجيش
وما بين السياسي بشكل شكرا لك اه عمر هاشم
فيها رئيس برنامج التحول الديمقراطي وخبير
شؤون البرلمانيه والحزبيه مركز الاهرام
للدراسات السياسيه وشكرا استاذ قنديل مدير
تحرير صحيفه الشروق المصريه شو كان
مشاهدينا الكرام لمتابعتكم والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
ام
[موسيقى]